what's the story on your relationship
with Jerry Seinfeld he's coming to LA
were going out to dinner whoa look at
this as it was Seinfeld was airing felt
Jerry loves cut other comics he really
truly does yes he's very generous that
way now what does that mean dinner like
are you gonna pay or is he gone well
this is how I'm like I get fixated pay
me I don't know how it's gonna work so I
go he's already there not long he's in a
seat
so prepared for you all prepared and I'm
like like normally I like to pay right
what I don't know Seinfeld's got a lot
of months got hate to break it here more
money you're playing Madison Square
Garden but he has more money than you
yeah I I don't know this guy order
$16,000 bottle of wine I don't want to
give the credit card upfront because I
don't know where this is gonna go right
he might be one of these guys that
orders $800 bottle of wine yeah and they
order more than one so what happened
with Seinfeld who paid so he gives me
the wine list
I look at it if you're ordering wine
right you're paying right that's right
if you get the wine list you better pay
so uh so I get the wine now I'm like oh
I don't know what wine I get cuz I'm
like if I get it cheaper wine is he
gonna like it maybe I got to step up my
game here and get like a Seinfeld ask
wine I can't even enjoy the night you
know you don't hear a thing he said
nothing I'm just thinking who's gonna
pay how's this gonna go down so bill is
bills not presented he goes all right
that a great time and we're getting I go
the Billy just take care of taken care
of now I'm like what just happened I
didn't see a bill coming payable not
right so after that after me and
Seinfeld begin to become friends I gotta
ask you something
we went out what was the bill right he
goes what I do is I take care of it all
before it's all taken care of
Oh class get there someone calls makes
the reservation gives the credit card
they tell them how much tip to put on
Wow it's it's just taken care all done
he has people for that it's just yeah so
because it eliminates now let me get it
yeah it's just it's done it's taken care
of just your money's no good here you
know that's that's interesting because
every time I've gotten to dinner with
him I seem to pick up the bill I don't
see anybody who actually has handled it
before him I'm a little [ __ ] offended